This video is brought to you by vincero
What's up wisecrack Michael here today. I want to talk about something.
We've all been watching a story that explores America's founding principles by
adding a hefty dose of hip hop parks and recreation.
You likely think of parks and rec as a show about small town,
government woodsmen, libertarianism,
or the dangers of doing business with the Safferstein.
No, she's the worst.
But what if it's an accidental masterclass and the struggles of founding a new
country now to say parks and rec is a show about America's founding might sound
like a stretch, but remember,
the co-creator might share is the same guy that made an entire sitcom about
philosophy.
It's like who died and left Aristotle in charge of ethics.
Okay. Even if Mike sure. Wasn't reading the notebooks of Thomas Jefferson,
his comedic musings on life and Pawnee may help us learn more about a very basic
problem for people trying to start a country from scratch.
That is how do you stop it from collapsing in on itself.
Welcome to this wisecrack edition on the political philosophy of parks and
recreation and spoilers.
Ahead for the show and Hamilton.
But before we get into it,
I'm going to give a shout out to this week's sponsor of in chair and Cheryl
watches are stylish, bold, and built to last.
They are hand-crafted and have the same feel as a luxury watch,
but at a fraction of the price right now, I'm wearing the coronal S in black.
And I really love how the watch elevates any outfit.
Even if you're in a t-shirt and jeans this past year,
even Cero has released four brand new collections,
including an automatic movement watch called the icon or rugged Explorer watch
called the outrider and a sleek race watch called the apex,
which includes a limited edition marble release that will be sold out soon to
celebrate the release of their new collections and their six year anniversary.
And Chera was holding their biggest sale ever.
You can get 30% off your entire order by checking out the link in the
description and ACE and summer is in full swing.
You might as well check out their sunglasses while you're there. Find out why.
And Cheryl has over 20 2005 star reviews by getting your own vincero accessory
today,
click the link in the description and take advantage of this year's biggest sale
with 30% off your entire order. Now, back to the show,
parks and rec follows the inner workings of Pawnee Indiana's parks department
headed by Ron Swanson and his over-eager deputy Leslie Knope.
Leslie has an almost childlike admiration for American style democracy and
believes that with good natured leaders,
the government has the ability to make our world a better place. However,
she is surrounded by people who are at best empathetic and at worst downright
hostile to her grand plan.
I don't want this parks department to build any parks because I don't believe in
government.
Forwarded at every step.
As she tries to build a park where an empty pit wants to take on big sugar or
stop people from drinking from water fountains like.
Yeah, so the idea is to make a fountain that he can't do that.
Before he was famous for being a deft Broadway lyricist Hamilton,
along with James Madison and John Jay wrote a series of articles meant to sway
public opinion towards the creation of a unified nation of States through the
constitution and a strong national government. You know,
the United States of America,
these articles referred to as the Federalist papers,
were responding to existing criticisms of the proposed union and preempted any
yet to come.
And while the stakes of forming a union out of 13 individual States and throwing
a Pawnee unity concert might not be quite the same.
These early debates about American government can help us better understand
what's really going on in parks and rec. So let's start with problem one,
the danger of factions,
whether you're a local parks department or the head of a national government.
There's one thing you got to watch out for different groups of people,
all with very specific interests,
all yelling at each other in a way that devolves into chaos.
No, you promise you promise. That's not fair.
Is that a question of fairness? It's separation to Russia, Kami back to Russia.
If you're a student of Pawnees town hall meetings, you might've noticed a theme,
no matter what level headed plan, Leslie and veils,
there's some person or group who feels like their rights as an American have
been trampled upon. Okay.
What's next income, sir. You don't pay your income tax.
That I pay income taxes,
none of the government's business try to make Pawnee healthier.
And this guy is mad. He has to go out of his way to the nearest paunch Berg.
Now, if I want to start my day off with a triple Decker pancake breakfast pizza,
I got to go the one that's 10 minutes away.
And that makes me 20 minutes late to work. Every day I work at home.
Have you ever considered not eating that for breakfast?
I'll never consider that during these meetings and throughout the show,
Leslie and the parks department are met with an onslaught of hyper specific and
constantly annoyed citizens and interest groups who are never satisfied with
anything. There isn't.
Disturbing lack of benches in Ranjit park.
Factions in turn trample on the rights of others.
Like when seniors can't learn how to not catch chlamydia,
because it offends the society for family stability foundation.
If we allow this film to be taught to our seniors, the next thing you know,
it'll be in our high schools that our kindergartens and before, you know,
we have babies and thong underwear, is that what you want? Yes,
that's what I want.
Believe it or not.
It was exactly this kind of chaos that James Madison was trying to avoid by
creating a federal Republic to unify the States. Sure.
He might not have meant bench people,
but he was acutely aware of how say one religious group could tie radically
impose their will on others. Madison in Federalist. Number 10,
defines a faction as a number of citizens,
whether a mounting to a majority or a minority of the whole or United and
actuated by some common impulse of passion or of interest adverse to the rights
of other citizens or to the permanent and aggregate interest of the community
while Leslie's chipper attitude tries to solve the problem of factions with
inclusivity.
So what I hear when I'm being yelled at is people caring
loudly at me.
Madison argues that the solution to factions is to either destroy their cause or
limit their effects and while removing the causes for the faction sounds
convenient.
Madison points out that the only ways you could do this would be by destroying
the Liberty that lets factions exist in the first place or more creepily,
giving every citizen the same opinions, same passions and the same interests.
In other words,
if Leslie simply indoctrinated everyone into her binder called there would be no
pesky, Jeremy jams trying to put a punch burger on her beloved park.
I want to sell this lot to poncho burger. Here's why we make money.
They make money. They make burgers. We eat burgers.
Since removing the causes of factions. Isn't really an option.
How does one limit their effects for Madison factions are especially bad in
smaller republics.
Local politics makes it easier for super rich neighborhood weirdos,
like the Newports to impose their will on an entire area. If you go bigger,
Madison thought the competing factions might balance each other out a bit,
but then again,
he didn't really foresee the rise of the internet or multinational corporations,
but that's a video for a different day. Parks and rec.
On the other hand has a novel solution to a certain kind of factionalism in the
time capsule episode. And this episode,
a man with a creepy Twilight obsession wants to get the book put in the town's
time capsule to impress his daughter, the town hall meetings,
predictably spiral out of control as groups and individuals with misaligned
interests,
all fight to have the Bible weird paintings and dead people's ashes included in
the project. We can get a little Madison in here. Sure.
Since it would be a huge overstep to try to eliminate the source of people's
feuding about whether Twilight is demonic propaganda or an important cultural
touchstone,
the role of government is to develop mechanisms for controlling the fallout.
One of Madison's solutions was to have a space for the rabble to express their
grievances while making sure the system kept their shenanigans contained.
In this light,
we might consider the town hall meetings as an important pressure valve for
public sentiments.
What are you still got a moron?
Why don't you have hand dryers in the park bathrooms?
There's so much more sanitary than paper towels.
People air their grievances might just keep the weirdos from lining up outside
city hall with muskets and weirdly.
This is a huge mechanism of the Constitution's design,
letting all the chaos and anger of a democracy be expressed without giving into
the actual unfiltered will of the people. There's two ways.
We can look at this on one hand,
having just survived a revolutionary war motivated by factional dispute between
England and the colonies. The founders understood the importance of controlling,
angry minorities, who would inevitably be at odds with government rule.
On the other hand,
they were equally worried about the poor masses who were larger numbers in the
landowning classes,
rising up and taking power from their buddies who own both land and people.
And that's not even getting into how afraid they were of slavery volts. Again,
a topic for another time besides revolts of the pores or slaves or both allied
together, Madison and his fellow Federalists had another problem.
How do we convince the skeptical States to join our new union?
And while Pawnee isn't even a state,
we can see some of the same exact problems at play in Indiana Eagleton.
Pawnees ritzy neighbors, the seeded from Pawnee long ago,
disgusted by the filth of the undesirable pores of their neighborhood.
That all changes. However, when they go bankrupt while Eagle,
then isn't pushing for a compromise over slavery. Thank God.
They are like many of the Southern States hesitant to give up their freedoms and
rejoin the town upon eight, built over hot spring with a microclimate,
all its own.
It's an example of how hard it can be to get different cities or States to join
together for the greater good Eagleton is richer cleaner.
The town hall meetings are exquisite. Look how pretty the people are.
Why would they ever want Pawnee ins to come ruining their nice parks?
Eagleton is in this sense, like an anti-federalists state, unlike an Eagle,
Tony and Leslie Knope sees the value in Pawnee being part of something greater
than itself. Even when Eagleton is broken full of condescending.
I live in Eagleton and frankly, I don't like the idea of living in Pawnee.
They're a little, what's the word afternoon money. And believe it or not,
Eagleton's bankruptcy is actually a pretty great stand in for one specific
hesitancy in joining into a union of States debt, have you seen Hamilton?
You'll remember the definitely historically accurate rap battle between Thomas
Jefferson and Alexander Hamilton and which they use their lyrical prowess to
debate the question of whether debts and wealth should be shared through the
federal government, or if a state being broke was their own dumb problems.
Oh, if the SU fits where we hit New York city,
that's a pain, I'm afraid don't tax the South.
Cause we got it made in the shade.
This was an important question in the wake of the revolutionary war as both the
federal government and the States were in massive debt to the tune of 54 and
$25 million respectively with paper money as useless as stock and entertainment,
seven 20 and no country wanting to loan money to deadbeat America.
Hamilton's big idea was to absorb all this debt at the federal level and
establish a national bank for heavily indebted States. This was awesome.
But for States like Maryland, Pennsylvania, North Carolina, and Virginia,
who already paid their debts and men getting taxed to pay off the debt of your
broke neighbors, somewhat like the debt ridden States,
Eagleton's only way to survive.
Their crushing debt is to be absorbed into Carney,
forming a new economic union of sorts Pawnees since they haven't repeatedly
failed to pay back,
their debtors extensively can borrow more money to build more parks in schools,
especially after the keen fiscal management of Ben Wyatt.
In the case of the constitution,
the idea was that safe France would be less willing to lend money to say New
Jersey and more willing to trust the cash with the larger and fiscally savvy
federal government.
So here parks and rec falls on the side of New York based hip hop artists,
Alexander Hamilton, who said that a national debt,
if it is not excessive will be to us in national blessing.
But now that we've seen why the founding fathers thought that faction should be
tolerated and why a union was stronger than a collection of States,
the question still remains is democracy, even a good system.
Do we really want the type of government that requires a years of meetings and
compromises to turn a pit into a community park?
So here we go with problem three, does democracy actually work?
We all know that America is a democracy and democracy is about we the people.
So obviously our friends, Hamilton, Madison and Jay got sweet democracy,
neck tattoos. And for everyone mad that,
well actually America is a democratic Republic.
Zip your burger hole for a second. We're getting there.
The founders were pretty skeptical about the whole while he,
the people part of the government and were downright opposed to a world in which
each citizen had a direct say in what's going on John Adams and the defense of
the constitution of the United States.
Flat-out worried that unbridled democracy would lead the masses to give up their
power immediately to some King or idols of their own creation.
He also worried like Madison that the pores would start using their power to Rob
the rich blind and to be fair that the rich,
when left to their own devices would simply Rob the poor blind it's worth noting
that Adams admired the British form of government with its balance of powers and
representative nature, parks and rec, despite being, Oh,
so optimistic about the power of one woman to change the world,
really dives into the show that is democracy they're city counselors serving for
way too long with their own dumbing Greenways and clear conflicts of interest.
Along with a bonkers ideas held by some of Pawnee citizens.
But isn't all food bad for you.
I've been eating lasagna and muffins every day of my life for 40 years.
And I feel terrible.
It was because of all this messiness that the founders preferred to call their
invention eight democratic Republic instead of a literal democracy for the
authors of the Federalist papers, commercial republics,
like ours will never be disposed to waste themselves and ruin his contentions
with each other.
They will be governed by mutual interest and will cultivate a spirit of mutual
Amity and conquered a Republic in the eyes of the founding fathers is a system
of government,
which is indirectly controlled by the people with many barriers between
individual citizens and direct decision-making at the government level.
In other words, you need a principal,
Leslie Noper and Perkins to act on behalf of this guy.
I'm not worried about swine flu. I already had the swine flu.
I'm worried about the turtle flu.
And rather than hoping for some shared patriotic interest Hamilton,
for one thought that it was commerce, not democratic ideals,
that would be the true unifying force of the union to put it bluntly.
They figured that people would get over their fights and squabbles.
If it would keep their bank balance, looking pretty,
this in turn would keep them faithful to the nation,
keeping their accounts in the black while we've more than covered the town
halls. We can consider this quote from the Federalist papers are not popular
assemblies, frequently subject to the impulses of rage, resentment, jealousy,
avarice, and of other irregular and violent propensities.
Is it not well known that their determinations are often governed by a few
individuals in whom they place confidence and are of course liable to be
tinctured by the passions and views of those individuals. In other words,
there's a few jerks who are going to push public sentiment in a pretty bad
direction while the media,
during their time amounted to rumors spread at the Tavern and printed pamphlets,
we can see the danger of misguided masses with Pawnees own gin soaked Katy
curric, Joan Callan, mezzo,
Calla mezzos talk show Pawnee today has the cloud to make or break local
political careers.
And it can do this all through using emotions like rage and jealousy to Rouse,
TV, addicted citizens in the service of the absolute worst ideas.
Yeah. How can you justify raising taxes for something that'll hurt the town?
But this of course leaves us with the question of whether the founders were
correct,
thinking that we weren't capable of handling an actual direct democracy and
instead needed the barriers of a Republic to keep us from ruining things.
After all,
we've got plenty of problems caused by special interest groups and career
politicians.
It's not that parks and rec is a perfect one-to-one stand in for the arguments
of Federalist versus anti-federalists,
but it can serve as a pretty good lesson in what these people were thinking.
But what do you think wisecrack does parks and rec show us the best that
American democracy is capable of and well-intentioned folks work together or
does it instead lay bare the problems and limitations inherent to a system of
government developed over 200 years before it was possible to slide into those
DNS, let us know what you think in the comments. Huge,
thanks to our amazing patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts.
And before you go,
I'm going to give one last shout out to VIN Cero for sponsoring this video,
check out the four new collections and the site's biggest sale of the year by
clicking the link in the description. When you use our link,
you can get 30% off your entire order.
So take advantage of this giant sale as always. Thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].